foreign
Valparaiso what's up Kyle
hey what's up Dr John how are you doing
I'm good my brother what about you man
hey I'm hanging in there uh life's
pretty crazy but but uh doing all right
thanks for calling man it means a lot to
me what's up
um yeah so almost a year ago
um I left my stable yet very
unfulfilling job
um just went all in on starting my own
business which was something that I
always wanted to do
um
also uh my wife and I we purchased our
first house in March and then we got
married in September so because why not
you know throw all this stuff in why not
all at once
um and we bought a pony anyways yeah so
it's my first business I've had
um and so it's it's stressful and um
I've noticed a lot of like some
unhealthy thought patterns that I've had
my whole life
um but they've really like come on
strong with this you know this big life
change
um and uh my wife is is very supportive
of me
um I feel very lucky to have her uh
sometimes though I feel like with these
you know these thought patterns
intrusive thoughts I can push her away
um so
to get more into detail on on that
um I've always had like a very active
mind I've struggled a lot with intrusive
thoughts obsessive thinking
perfectionism
um and it's hard for me to control
sometimes and so like something little
could come up in the day let's say with
my business like oh um I'm not where I
think I should be or I'm not um didn't
make the right choice or I'm not making
enough money I don't have enough
customers and then you know something
little could just snowball very quickly
go from zero to 100 very quickly and I
can't stop it and then all of a sudden
you know the world's ending and I want
to stop you know quit the business
because I'm failing
um and so these outside things have like
very strong hold on on how I how I feel
let me interrupt you there what's that
let me interrupt you there
you have given external
people and systems and opinions that
sort of grasp
right and this this will be the
Cornerstone of you either getting well
or you not
because if you believe that you are
subject to that you are a slave to these
outside things this the reports the what
then you will always be spinning your
wheels duct taping over the the the the
the leaks in the dam right you will
always be trying to to patch over well
I'm anxious over here and I'm not
sleeping over here so I'm just gonna
ignore this I'm gonna quit doing this
I'm gonna stop talking to this person
I'll quit this job and get this job I'll
quit that job and get this job you're
going to be moving around until you take
ownership over
huh
my body's been trying to keep me safe
for a long long time
and it does that by trying to dress
rehearse Tragedy by hot trying to think
of the worst thing that could possibly
happen ever and reverse engineer what we
need to do right now to prevent fill in
the blank uh there's a great quote by
um Victor Frankl I think it is that and
I'll I'll butcher the quote but
anxiety will fill as much space as you
give it
and so what I would ask you is
what's the earliest you can remember
these intrusive thoughts where you would
just Spin and spin and spin and spin and
spend
um
I mean since apple is probably like you
know seven or eight
um
you know I don't have like the specific
examples but I would just always be in
my head and and struggle to
to like pay attention school for example
um uh I don't I don't know like exactly
what I was thinking about but I could
just always remember
just always being in my head
was speaking your opinions out loud
something that was frowned upon
um no not not in my not hot in like my
house or anything but it it was it was
always difficult for me like I struggled
with you know self-esteem as a kid
um what's the origin of that though so
I'm trying to get at
yeah
um
somebody told you either affirmatively
like oh you're too small to play ball or
you're not fast enough or your military
material they told you crap like that or
they didn't look at you and say
God Almighty every day I'm so grateful
that I get to be your mom I get to be
your dad I get to be your teacher
yeah
um
I mean my parents are awesome they they
um
they uh best parents I you know I could
ask for
um so I think I I just feel like you
know the
I mean I thought I was born with uh the
the attention issues and the the
um
you know the struggling to focus and
intrusive thoughts I mean maybe that's
not how that works but that's what it
feels like the way the the best way I've
heard it explained is from the great
brene Brown she says in genetics loads
the gun but environment pulls the
trigger
right and what's beautiful about that is
is that you and I can both be wired up
for certain things
but if it's the environment that sets
these things off that means there's
something in it that we can control
and so instead of trying to solve for
the each individual anxiety I mean
anxious in front of people I'm anxious
for this thing I mean I want to create a
non-anxious life
yeah and I want to work from there and
so you need to hear me say out loud
rumination
worrying
literally solves nothing
nothing absolutely nothing
and it it was like a light bulb moment
when I first someone first told me that
I think it was a counselor a friend of
mine first told me that
because I my my life was like a better
mind remember that movie I was always
waiting for this so that this could
happen and then I could sell this and
then this was going to happen and I was
talking to my wife this morning in fact
I'm writing another book on anxiety and
this morning my wife and I were talking
about it and I asked her what was it
like and she said you always had a new
thing that was going to be the final
solution and she said I would listen to
you and you were nuts you were going to
get this other job or you just needed to
do this one thing so that this one
person would see you so you could get
this promotion and then make this much
money and then it would be okay or right
I'm just gonna I'm gonna go be a full
vegan I'm gonna be a raw vegan and
that's gonna fix that I just always had
a thing and I was so confident in the
thing she said that she felt crazy and
she knew she wasn't crazy but her body
told her she was anyway you see what I'm
saying like it's always this thing until
I realized none of those things are
going to solve
a life that has nothing to Anchor into
right so let's back all the way out
give me the names just the first names
of two or three or four men in your life
that you love and you hang out with
regularly and you don't have to hide
anything from
um
first names you said yep
okay
um
Scott
[Music]
um
I think that's about it that's it and
you see those guys those two guys
regularly once a week once every time
regularly
not regularly I uh what did they say
when you told them hey I'm really
struggling with anxiety
um
they uh
I haven't told I think I told Kyle about
it here's what I'm getting at here's
what I'm getting at
you have to have people in your life
that you can be honest and tell the
truth to and you don't have that
right you have people in your life that
you protect and you take care of and you
hang out with
but not people that I would consider in
your tribe
right and my guess is if your marriage
is like mine
you've begun to keep secrets from your
wife about how scared you are that you
quit your your steady job
that you thought starting your own
business you'd be a little more
successful than you are right now and
you thought it would make you feel
differently and it hasn't
and
so you sit on that because you don't
want to freak her out or make her any
more nervous than she already is and all
that and that creates space and that
space is called dishonesty you're not
telling her the truth
and she feels it doesn't know what to do
with it and so she tries to solve it
and she creates a whole a world that she
can survive in
because she doesn't know what's
happening in your world it just feels
Electric in there
and your body feels that she is heading
off into another Direction so it spins
faster you see what I'm saying this
whole thing creates a dance yeah
yeah and so for the first time in your
life probably
you've got to find a couple of people
including her and say the words I'm
scared
I am spitting out my thoughts are
spinning out I'm exhausted and the only
way I only path forward I can see is to
work faster and harder
and I don't know if I got that
you have to speak these fears out loud
because here's what your body will do it
will link the terror part of it's your
brain
with your frontal lobe with the thinking
part and it will go oh he recognizes the
threats we don't have to keep banging on
these drums in the back of his head
he's driving he's aware
and then you can actually start solving
some of these things because the alarms
will begin to go down that's number one
that's connectivity number two are you
safe do you owe money to people
no no you don't owe anybody any money
no okay are you do you have abusive
employees are you in a unsafe business
have you bitten off more than you could
chew with your business
no no not at all okay are y'all making
money you're gonna make your make your
house notes and things
yeah yeah Okay cool so the more pair
mortgage and stuff oh great so you just
said you didn't owe anybody any money
beside your mortgage who do you owe
money to
uh student loans car notes credit cards
our student loans
um
[Music]
okay when I say do you owe anybody any
money and you say no those are people
you owe money to okay okay I am
convinced I I I heard it wrong I am
convinced with all of my guts
that the our frontal lobes are thinking
brain
will can understand oh this is a great
purchase this is zero percent down this
is a good interest rate or whatever
but the amygdala the part of I probably
even go as far as say the HPA axis the
entire system knows
if one thing happens in this business we
don't make the car note they come take
the car it ruins my credit I can never
borrow again I don't have a bit rate see
where I start spinning out on us I'm
convinced with all of my guts
that if you owe money to somebody your
body will not let you rest because it
knows at its core level
that you're not safe
because at any moment this stuff goes
away
and so whatever you got to do I want you
to stay on the line I'm going to send
you some stuff I'm going to send you the
Financial Peace University the class
that gets to help you get out of debt
and I know you didn't call for this but
I'm convinced that it's a it's a
marriage tool also and it's an
anti-anxiety tool also because it's
going to force you and your wife to sit
down and talk through what are our goals
and who do we want to become as a couple
and it's going to force you into a plan
if you if you choose to you can throw in
the garbage for all I care but it's
going to cheat it's going to force you
into a plan that's going to help you not
owe anybody anything and it's going to
let your brain finally go
and I'm telling you this as a guy that
had a six-figure mortgage and six-figure
student loan debts because I got a bunch
of stupid degrees actually they're not
stupid I'm proud of them I had a bunch
of degrees and I had a bunch of credit
card debt I had a car note
and the difference between that guy
and me now is a radically different
person
the stressors in my life are tenfold
what they were
but my body isn't constantly if we I get
fired tomorrow that'll suck but I'm not
gonna miss a meal No One's Gonna Come
Take My House away from me
you see what I'm saying that is a that
is a different Legacy that's number two
so we're talking about connection we're
talking about safety and the third one
is autonomy
who decides what you do tomorrow is it
you or is it this business that you have
a business loan on is it Toyota Motor
Company
who decides what you do tomorrow
who decides no
sure
can you take can you take tomorrow off
and just go spend a day with your wife
uh probably not no you can't that means
somebody else is pulling your strings
and so what I want you to do is to go
down a list of who has their hooks in
you
who decides what you do tomorrow
now and I obviously tomorrow is is maybe
it's a bad example maybe you got a big
business meeting and things like that
that's I totally get that
but I'm talking on a global level
if your brain knows
that you are not driving the car
somebody else says you've outsourced
that to a mortgage company to a boss to
a business that you're underwater in
whatever it's not going to let you rest
it doesn't it can't afford for you to go
all the way under into deep REM sleep
because you're not safe
they can't afford for you to spend time
having sex
this isn't a time to reproduce this is a
time to not die right that's the it's an
ancient system that we got designed to
keep us from getting eaten by bears but
it's running all the time all right so
backing all the way all the way out
here's what I've had to do I keep and if
you're watching this on YouTube I've got
this I've
got a notebook that I got you may have
heard me talk about this on the show and
I still carried around with me
everywhere everywhere and I've got not
hundreds I've got dozens of these
journals over the last decade that I've
got in a drawer in my house in a filing
cabinet that I'm still deciding whether
to give to my kids or not one day or
just putting them in the fire pit
outside
but it's a thoughts Journal
and here's what I do I I keep my
gratitude journal in here now
every day I wake up and say hey here's
five things I'm grateful for and that's
just that's just a spiritual practice
that I recommend you do the second thing
is every time your brain starts to spin
out on you
stop literally say out loud nope nope
stop nope
and write down is this true whatever the
story is so here's a good example
um my daughter I think I've told this
this on the show before
um I kissed my six-year-old daughter on
the forehead as I was walking out of the
of the house to go to the gym at like
five in the morning or something
and she turns around and yells I wish
you never existed all you ever tell me
is that I'm smart and Brilliant and
beautiful and I can't live like this I'm
not going to take it anymore
and I was like whoa and so I walked
outside on the front porch and the first
thought that came in my mind the very
first thought is
of course because you suck at being a
dad
you're never here you're always on the
road you're always prepping for some
talk or writing some stupid book of
course she doesn't want you kissing on
their head because you suck at this
and that haunted me for about 45 seconds
and then I made it down to the my
basement gym and I pulled this little
notebook out and I wrote down in it you
suck at being a dad period
and then I looked at it and I asked
myself the magic question is this true
the answer is no
it's not I'm a great dad I'm a good dad
maybe I'm not great I'm good at it and I
work really hard at it
and in that process I stopped the cycle
before it started the one that begins to
solve for you're a bad dad and fills my
body with cortisol and adrenaline and
now I'm off to the races and what I need
to do I need to lose weight but I can't
lose weight because I've been doing this
and I got to quit my job but I can't put
my job you see you know what I'm talking
about because you're good on that road
all the time right
so I'm gonna stop that sucker on the
front end because I know that ruminating
and worrying is not helping my problems
and now that I know that I'm going to
consciously practice stopping that train
before it leaves the station right as
it's leaving the station and it
occasionally one gets out and when it
goes I'm gonna smile at it I'm gonna be
curious about and be like oh there it
goes
oh boy here we go it's like getting
stuck on a roller coaster and like it so
it's gonna go here we go I'm gonna be
curious about it I'm not going to allow
myself to get anxious about being
anxious again
right
and that's where you are you're worried
about being worried about things at this
point right
yes exactly yes let me ask you this last
question
is your business going to make it
um I hope so I'm not sure nope own
reality is it gonna make it or not make
it
it's gonna make it what's the business
it is uh residential cleaning business
okay
and so it's like uh you hire people to
go clean clean homes
yeah okay are you making a profit
a little bit not much okay what's the
scalability
availability
um I think it's it's
syllable
um
I'm just working on getting more clients
and then so I could hire more teams and
uh I think it's
I mean there's a lot of a lot of people
living here so I think there's a lot
a lot of um opportunity
so here's what I want you to do I want
you to find two or three people
either in the Valparaiso or get in a car
and drive a few hours to
a couple of cities that are around you
that are big go over to Indianapolis
go over to Chicago find somebody who
runs a cleaning business
I want you to offer to buy them
dinner
and just say I need some mentoring and
coaching
I need you to walk me through what does
this look like
like what does success look like
how have you found success in getting
new clients or is it it's it's word of
mouth is it this is it that
um here in the office a whole bunch of
people use the same crew some use it a
couple times a week because they're rich
other people use it once a month use
them once a month but it all is word of
mouth right so I sit with somebody who's
doing the thing you want to do at the
level you want to do it
and ask them humbly take a knee and say
hey I'm into this thing up to my
eyeballs I'm starting to spin out a
little bit
where the pitfalls where I need to go
from here
and you're going to get some real wisdom
not from YouTube not from you doing back
of the napkin math or coming up with yet
another spreadsheet now the spreadsheet
you're gonna get some real wisdom from
some people who have already been there
okay so hang on the line I'm gonna send
you Financial Peace University I'm going
to see the every dollar app for free too
for a year I'm also going to send you a
copy of own your pass change your future
two I'm just need two copies I want you
to read one I want your wife to read the
other one okay I want you all to do this
together okay and I'm gonna send you a
copy of my book redefining anxiety I'm
just gonna load you up brother because I
am you I've been there
and I need you to hear me say before I
get off the phone there is a light at
the end of this tunnel if and only if
you want it
because anxiety keeps us safe until it
burns everything else to the ground
ask yourself do I want to be free from
this and if you do I got the roadmap for
you my brother